the biden administration cuts off
monoclonal antibody supply to florida
citing equity the media continued to
push covet panic for kids and joe
biden's approval ratings have fallen off
a cliff i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro
[Music]
show ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit expressvpn.com
ben and by the way now's a good time to
remind you expressvpn.com is great every
time you connect to an unencrypted
network in cafes hotels airports etc
your online data is not secure any
hacker on the same network can gain
access to and steal your personal data
passwords financial details you name it
and today it doesn't take advanced
technical knowledge to hack somebody
just some cheap hardware is necessary a
smart 12 year old could do it that's why
i recommend expressvpn expressvpn
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet so
hackers cannot steal your sensitive data
not only is it incredibly secure it is
also super easy to use i know this
because i downloaded it on my phone i
downloaded it on my computer that took
one click took like a minute to download
and then i hit the button and i'm good
to go i am now protected from prying
eyes expressvpn works on phones laptops
tablets all your devices so you can stay
secure on the go secure your online data
today by visiting expressvpn.com
that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn dot com slash ben you
can get an extra three months for free
expressvpn.com go check them out right
now expressvpn.com
ben alrighty so the big news of the day
is that joe biden has basically decided
that remember all that monoclonal
antibody stuff that rhonda sansas was
talking about and members of the media
were suggesting that he was just sort of
making it up why aren't you focusing on
vaccines and the answer was he was
focusing on vaccines and then for people
who did not take the vaccine or for
people who got a serious breakthrough
infection or for people who would not
take the vaccine it is very good to have
monoclonal antibodies on hand because
they are a very effective treatment from
regenerons the media immediately shifted
into anti-desantis mode which meant that
we were all blowing monoclonal
antibodies out of proportion we really
should you know it's really not a a
thing why are we focusing on this thing
and not only that rhonda sans is
probably doing this because he might own
stock in regeneron or one of his donors
own stock in regeneron it's probably all
about that well now it turns out of
course that ronda sanchez was correct
because as he has throughout this
pandemic rhonda sances has been
following the science
and so he ordered a lot of monoclonal
antibody treatment because florida had a
really big spike you may have noticed
this summer and the treatments that were
available included monoclonal antibodies
well now the biden administration has
stepped in and they've said okay we're
no longer going to allow states to
simply order monoclonal antibody
treatments now we're going to federalize
the process and in the process remove
doses from places like florida
which is pretty obviously a revenge play
by the biden administration against
states like florida and like texas
because the idea is that they're going
to what pick up doses and then not send
them where they're most needed see
here's the thing about the market
especially when you have states who are
competing to get a limited supply of a
good the states that have greater need
of the good are generally willing to pay
more
in these states like florida that were
in dire circumstances should pay money
where states like new york were not and
if new york spikes then new york
presumably will want to buy a lot of
monoclonal antibody treatments if states
like vermont which by the way is 88 of
adults in vermont are now vacant they
have their all-time high in delta
infections because delta is infectious
and herd immunity seems not to be really
a thing when it comes to delta
if vermont wants monoclonal antibodies
they should go out and get monoclonal
antibodies but the biden administration
has decided and it is obvious what they
are doing that they seek to depress i
mean at this point they are basically
just rationing medical care
so breitbart has a very good report
on this from hannah blow
the biden administration this week
slashed the doses of life-saving
coronavirus antibody treatments in
florida giving the state less than half
of what it is of what is needed for a
routine week prioritizing what they call
equitable distribution uh-huh equitable
not need-based equitable now you'll
remember that in the public health
context the biden administration when
they use the term equity what they
really mean is we're not going to give
this treatment to the people who need it
most we're going to give it to the
people we want to have it most so they
did this first when they proposed the
cdc that they were going to tranch out
vaccines not by age which is the number
one complicating factor for covid but
instead by race
remember they suggested they were going
to give a disproportionate number of the
vaccines to black americans not to
elderly americans which made no sense
because the actual absolute number of
black americans who would then die would
be higher
because again if you have a certain
number of black americans who are in the
plus 65 crowd those folks are much more
likely to die than the 20 year old black
americans the the cdc didn't care they
were going to try and give a lot of
doses to people who are 20 and not a lot
of doses to people who are 65 and then
there was public outcry and blowback and
the cdc revised its own standards
whenever they say equity what they mean
is we are not going to actually
triage this situation and get the doses
where they are most necessary instead we
are going to simply focus in on who are
our political constituencies and how do
we get them what they want
the biden administration this week began
to cut the distribution of monoclonal
antibodies to red states like florida
and alabama contending those states
including texas mississippi tennessee
georgia and louisiana are comprising too
big a share of the supply in recent
weeks 70
okay well shouldn't we actually
determine the supply by where the
hospitalizations and deaths are
occurring
wouldn't that be the way that you
normally do this
it's sort of like saying that you have a
heavy urban area and a lot of rural
areas and there are a lot of car
accidents in the heavy urban area but we
only have a certain number of doctors
who are available for car crashes and we
know that in the rural areas you know
those people are our voters what if we
just send all the doctors for the car
crashes that's the rural areas which
have fewer per capita car crashes and
those people in the in the cities i mean
they chose to live there so they get in
a car crash really kind of their problem
right
a spokesperson for the us department of
health and human services said hhs will
determine the amount of product each
state and territory receives on a weekly
basis state and territorial health
departments will subsequently identify
sites that will receive product and how
much the official continued claiming the
system will quote help maintain
equitable distribution both
geographically and temporally across the
country providing states and territories
with consistent fairly distributed
supply over the coming weeks and all the
ambiguity lives in that word fairly
because again normally you don't have to
worry about what's fair you just have to
worry about who's sick
as soon as you substitute the word fair
for ill in that particular sentence
you have decided that the ill don't
matter all that matters to you is your
political priority
right instead it should be that the
geographic and temporal distribution
should be rooted in who is ill again
they don't care about that they care
about the politics
governor ron desantis of course is
cracking back against the biden
administration
and by the way this just demonstrates
the lie okay so first of all you'll go
back like a week and a half joe biden is
yelling at the unvaccinated and one of
the things he says in his speech yelling
at the unvaccinated is we're going to
radically ramp up the amount of
monoclonal antibody available to people
unless you happen to live in a red state
in which case you're screwed
we're increasing the availability of new
medicines recommended by real doctors
not conspiracy conspiracy theorists
the monoclonal on antibody treatments
have been shown to reduce the risk of
hospitalization up to 70 percent for
unvaccinated people at risk of
developing severe severe disease
we've already distributed 1.4 million
courses of these treatments to save
lives
and reduce the strain on hospitals
so there was like a week and a half ago
talking about how important it is to
distribute these monoclonal antibody
treatments right it's super important to
distribute these things and then he's
like what if we just shifted the way we
distribute these things so that the
people who are sickest don't get them
and people in blue states do
if donald trump had done this you know
what the reaction would be in fact there
were rumors early on remember there are
all these rumors the jared kushner and
those blue states they don't need their
ventilators now that never happened
right the blue states got their
ventilators but joe biden's actually
doing it everything they accused trump
of doing biden actually does and the
media cheer like the good little seals
that they are we'll get some more of
this in just one second first let us
talk about a simple fact life is
unexpected so you need life insurance
right let's say that one day you just
decide you're going to paint a tunnel on
a rock because you want to catch a
roadrunner and the roadrunner just sails
right through the tunnel you follow him
bam you knock right into the rock and as
you concuss yourself and you lie on the
floor dying you think yourself man i
really should have listened to shapiro
and gotten life insurance via policy
genius policy genius makes it easy to
compare quotes from over a dozen top
insurers all in one place why compare
you could save 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius you could save 1300 bucks
or more per year on life insurance by
using policy genius to compare policies
the licensed experts and policy genius
work for you not the insurance companies
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process that kind of service has
earned policy genius thousands of five
star reviews across trustpilot and
google and eligible applicants can get
covered in as little as a week thanks to
an award-winning policy option that
swaps the standard medical exam
requirement for a simple phone call this
exclusive policy was recently rated
number one by forbes advisor it's higher
than options from ladder ethos and
bestow getting started is simple first
you head on over to policygenius.com
shapiro
in minutes you can work out how much
life insurance coverage you need and
compare personalized quotes to find your
best price when you're ready to apply
policy genius handles all the rest head
on over to policygenius.com shapiro gets
started right now policy genius when it
comes to insurance it's nice and quite
important to get it right okay so
according to breitbart the feds have now
delivered less than half of the
necessary doses to florida this week
according to cbs 12 they sent 30 950
doses according to numbers from the
governor's office and confirmed by the
department of health normally the state
needs about 72 000 doses a week to meet
the current needs on the ground
christina pusha the press secretary for
desantis blasted the biden
administration's move suggested quote
every corporate media outlet that
publishes sensational stories about
overflowing hospitals in the south
should first demand answers from the
biden administration about why they are
restricting the supply of life-saving
coveted treatment to the south
she said supply of monoclonal antibody
treatment to florida alabama tennessee
texas and other southern states
restricted by the biden administration
with no real explanation besides equity
how is it equitable to only send
treatment for half the floridians who
need it and no state sites in alabama
so ron desantis slammed joe biden over
all of this as well he should here was
desantis
we are very very concerned uh with the
biden administration and the hhs's
recent
abrupt sudden announcement that they are
going to dramatically cut the number of
monoclonal antibodies that are going to
be sent to the state of florida we think
it will make a difference in these other
states but man to just kind of pull the
rug out from anyone a week after the
president himself said they were going
to be increasing the distributions by 50
percent uh it's very very problematic
it is very problematic and if you look
at the timeline when he says it's abrupt
it is absolutely abrupt
phil kerpin over at the washington
examiner he has an entire timeline
demonstrating that until like five
seconds ago there was an actual
guarantee to florida that they were
going to get a certain number of doses
and then everything just switched
right as of september 9th president
biden announced his path out of the
pandemic a six-pronged comprehensive
national strategy to combat covet at 19.
and he announced that they would
increase the average weekly pace of
shipments of free monoclonal antibody
treatments to states by a further 50
in september and then september 13th hhs
announced they were taking complete
control and doing weekly distributions
for all states and territories that same
day that afternoon the federal
department of health
communicated to h the florida department
of health rather communicated to hhs the
weekly need for just the 25 state run
sites of about 36 000 doses when hhs
mentioned the state receiving the order
for all state sites and distributing the
florida department of health
specifically asked if such a shift would
apply to all facilities in the state
providing treatment hhs said this was
not the case and did not provide any
indication of any upcoming limitation to
supply
and then the very next day they sent an
email to all stakeholders indicating a
shift to an allocation strategy had
occurred that day
and they were contradicting what they
had just told the florida department of
health this is obviously an eminently
political and what is this really about
this is really about joe biden and the
biden administration determining that if
you are in a southern state you do not
deserve the vaccine
this is purely political
because let's be real about this there
are major population centers in the
united states where there's huge levels
of vaccine refusal i'm specifically
talking here about black
constituencies across the united states
huge levels of vaccine refusal and i'm
par or more than
quote unquote trump supporters
and i'm not seeing any talk whatsoever
about denying treatment to people based
on that so if the basic idea is that you
get covered because you decided you
didn't want to get a vaccine
and then the federal government says
okay well you're on your own because you
did that then that should theoretically
be equally applied
otherwise what's the excuse
really what's the excuse
so the so biden himself says well it's
about texas and florida refusing
quote-unquote life-saving measures what
are these supposed life-saving measures
things like mask mandates
now again mass mandates have been tried
in nearly every state in the union there
is very little evidence that mass
mandates have done a damn bit of good
when people are scared of the virus they
put on a mask when they are not scared
of virus they don't put on the mass
which is why you see in every state
including new york and california that
after a mass mandate is put in place
usually what happens there's a big spike
the spike starts to decline and then a
government actor being late on the ball
as always says mass mandate
and then the
the
spike continues to decline
we're on the other side of the of the
of the arithmetic curve right we're on
the other side of the curve already and
they say well it's because of this right
so the curve looks like this and then
mass mandate comes in here and then just
continues to decline and then three
months later there's a big spike and
where was your mass mandate well very
often it was still in place
this is happening all over the place so
he thinks mass mandates are the solution
or he thinks that
forcing businesses to vaccine mandate is
going to make this sort of stuff happen
when the reality is i mean i'm talking
to people every single day who are
vaccine hesitant and all that his
vaccine mandate nonsense has done is
pushed these people into a harder
position they've hardened their
positions it's now made them more
ideologically prone
to not only refusing the vaccines but
saying i'm happy to lose my job you've
turned what was a health decision into a
liberty decision for a lot of people and
people are going to double down on what
i think is a bad decision with regard to
vaccines but an understandable one with
regard to liberty but here's joe biden
basically saying you don't deserve to
get monoclonal antibody treatment i mean
that's really what this is about if you
don't do what i want you to do on mass
mandates in schools for example or if
you don't do what i want you to do with
regard to vaccine mandates for employers
now really if you're about getting the
vaccinated vaccinated and denying them
treatment
then there should be a simple
a simple policy right it would be a
vicious and cruel policy which is why he
doesn't want to do it out loud but he's
just doing it by state and trying to
focus in on red states but if the simple
quote-unquote moral policy here is you
don't get vaccinated you get that as
easier on your own that should equally
apply across states should it not but
it's not here is biden
but we're facing a lot of pushback
especially from some of the republican
governors
the governors of florida and texas are
doing everything they can to undermine
the life-saving requirements that i
propose this is the worst kind of
politics
because it's putting the lives of
citizens of their states
especially children at risk
and i refuse to give into it
okay again this sort of tyranny from the
federal government that ron desantis is
the actual tyrant because he refuses to
force businesses
to mandate that people have vaccines so
rhonda sansa says you're allowed to be
free make your own call in the state of
florida by the way if you're a business
and you want a vaccine mandate you can
still do that
but you actually can
so ron desantis says that
and joe biden's like he's the tyrant and
it's his fault so i'm now going to
deprive you of the treatment you need
and nowhere else in healthcare nowhere
else in the healthcare field do we do
anything like this it just does not
exist this notion that if you did not
take measures to protect yourself and
then you get hurt or you get sick we are
going to deny you treatment that does
not exist in the healthcare field
my wife the doctor heard about this and
you said what in the world is this
what in the world is this notion that if
somebody did not take measures to
protect themselves and then they got
hurt that the medical establishment is
supposed to refuse them treatment as
opposed to triaging by level of risk to
them level of risk to their health right
well this doesn't exist in like if
you're in a car crash and you weren't
wearing a seatbelt and they bring you
into the hospital does anybody go oh
this this jackass wasn't wearing a seat
belt because he gets what he deserves
and you know he's got some pressure on
from a hematoma and his skull but we're
just going to let that go and just let
that blame that that brain bleed
continue
no one does this
okay but but joe biden is pretty openly
doing this he's punishing states that
don't do what he wants
by centralizing monoclonal antibody
treatment distribution when the state of
florida was basically doing it on its
own already the state of florida was
already like we're getting the doses
guys
the biden administration says the
restrictions are in place to ensure
every state can obtain enough of the
drug
florida got about 30 000 doses in the
last week texas ranked second
the the goal here really is that he's
trying to cut off desantis at the knees
because here's the nice thing for him
joe biden
if things get worse in florida which
they're not things are much better in
florida the strain on the hospital
system has been relieved you can see
every single curve including
hospitalization and death in florida is
now down so we have hit the other side
of the curve we did a couple of weeks
ago in florida the next curve is likely
the next big spike is likely to be
midwestern and northeastern
okay but the goal here for biden is if
more people die in florida then he
doesn't have to worry about running
against desantis and florida it's so
overtly political it's insane
by the way this has been the schtick all
throughout the pandemic every death that
happened under trump was trump's fault
every debt that happens under biden is
governor's fault that's the way this
magic happens according to the media
biden tweeted something similar
here is joe biden's tweet yesterday
he tweeted out republican governors in
states like texas and florida are doing
everything they can to undermine the
public health requirements that keep
people safe really because the rates of
vaccination particularly for the elderly
in florida stack up pretty well against
virtually all other major states in the
united states what are what are these
measures to undermine public health
requirements keeping people safe
forcing people to mask up
post-vaccination forcing children to
mask up signs any evidence
forcing employers to fire people and
take the food off their table if they
don't want to get the vaccine
he says they're playing politics with
the lives of their citizens especially
children i refuse to give into it
especially children stuff is he talking
about
i've got three kids his kids are all
grown you think i'm playing politics
with my kids
i care about my kids a hell of a lot
more than joe biden does and i care
about my kids enough to know that my
five-year-old should not be forced to
wear a mask and eat outside on the
pavement every damn day
but apparently i just want to risk the
life of my kids according to joe biden
really incredible stuff we'll get to
more of this in just one second because
again it comes down to if you oppose joe
biden you are bad he doesn't have to he
doesn't have to cite science he doesn't
have to cite data nothing all he has to
do is say that you are at fault if you
wish to live free and make decent health
decisions for your family and then if
you get sick he's going to remove
the measures that are available for
every other human being but you don't
get it because you refuse to follow his
dictates it's tyrannical garbage
into more of this in one second first
let us talk about a simple fact and that
is that you need a better night's sleep
okay sleep matters an awful lot and this
is why i rely heavily on my helix sleep
mattress helix sleep has a quiz it takes
just two minutes to complete it matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you sleep everybody's unique
helix knows that they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot mattresses
great for spinal alignment to prevent
morning aches and pains even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers so
if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress you
match to the mattress comes right to
your door shipped for free you don't
ever need to go to a mattress store
again they've got a 10-year warranty you
get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
helix even has financing options and
flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away just
head on over to
helixleep.com take their two minutes
sleep quiz they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixlead.com go check
them out right now that's
helixsleep.com for 200 bucks off your
mattress order and
two free pillows for our listeners okay
so the white house is basically
admitting what they are doing
so jen's hockey was asked about this
we're not restricting supply we're just
you know restricting supply
over the last month given the rising
cases due to the delta variant and the
lower number of vaccination rates in
some of these states like florida like
texas just seven states are making up 70
percent of the orders our supply is not
unlimited and we believe it should be
equitable across states across the
country
a lack of supply so why cut them to
those states only if there's no
republicans i think our role as the as
the government overseeing the entire
country is to be equitable in how we
distribute we're not going to give a
greater percentage to florida over
oklahoma nor do i think are you
suggesting that
okay that's that's insane the dismissive
nastiness of gensake really is pretty
extraordinary
i mean that she's dismissing people
dying in hospitals that's what she's
doing right there
okay she said it sounds all it sounds
all equitable if you say equitable over
and over enough then three times and it
appears like beetlejuice
okay equity just appears there's only
one problem you don't tranch out
treatments by percentage of population
you do it by who has the cases
there's not an er on planet earth that
would handle this the way that the
federal government is handling this and
it is done purely out of spite
that's all this is and it's spite for a
particular population namely people they
perceive to be trump supporters
that is what they are doing and how do i
know that it's about trump supporters
and not mere vaccine hesitancy
because that is perfectly obvious they
are not equally angry at all people who
are hesitant to take the vaccine
depending on who you are the white house
will be your very bestie they will call
you up they'll try to massage you into
getting the vaccine
only if you're a white house supporter
if however you oppose joe biden
then go ahead and die sucker as jimmy
kimmel might put it
okay so how do i know this because
you will recall that last week there was
a
fascinating little tit between nicki
minaj and joy reid in which nicki minaj
tweeted out a bizarre story about her
cousin's friend
in trinidad
having swollen testicles and impotence
because of the vaccine which of course
is silly there's no scientific evidence
that the vaccine causes swollen
testicles or impotence
and that is that is a very silly
contention
but then joy reid sounded off and she
went after nicki minaj and nicki minaj
said that she was going after her
because of a race and it was all very
entertaining
now let's assume for a second that the
person who tweeted this out was not a
famous rap artist
most famous for shaking her posterior
and being a democrat let's let's say for
a second that this had been a country
western star who had said
my cousin down in alabama
got swollen balls from the vaccine
do you think the white house would have
reached out
what do you think or do you think it
would have earned extraordinary mockery
from the white house
i i have a feeling i know which way this
would go
right if somebody on the right had said
something as bizarre and stupid as nicki
minaj the white house would have said
this is bizarre and stupid and
inexcusable because this person has
millions and millions of followers
instead
you get from the white house yeah we
called up nicki minaj we're trying to
talk to nicki minaj
okay the reason for that is not because
of her millions of followers because
again it depends on who's saying the
thing
the reason they are doing this is
because nicki minaj they believe is on
their political side of the aisle so
they will give her a lot more
credibility and they will try to talk
her into it and they'll be sweet and
nice now here's the thing they should be
nice and they should be trying to talk
people into it regardless of your
political position as i've said a
thousand times i have individually on a
one-to-one level tried to talk probably
100 people into taking the vaccine and
i've been successful maybe 25 30 of the
time doesn't matter you still have to
talk to people on an individual level
the white house doesn't do that if
you're from florida go ahead and die
sucker and if you're nicki minaj we're
going to call you up and try and we're
going to try and we're going to spend an
hour explaining to you the data behind
vaccinations and ball swelling
here is uh here is jen saki doing this
it's
unreal we offered a call
with nicki minaj and one of our doctors
to answer questions she had about the
safety and effectiveness of the vaccine
this is pretty standard and something we
do all the time it was a very early
stage call at a staff level staff to
staff
and we weren't even at the point of
discussing we're not even at the point
of discussing i should say at this point
the mechanisms or the formats or
anything along those lines it was simply
an offer to have a conversation and uh
an early stage call
look how sweet they are to nicki minaj
how sweet they are to particular people
who are vaccine hesitant or promoting
overt vaccine misinformation like nicki
minaj did look how sweet they're being
however
if nicki minaj were a white guy in
florida who refused to take the vaccine
and then got sick and needed monoclonal
antibody treatment then well you know
equity suggests that we have to send
this dose to a place that doesn't need
it because there are no shortages
currently in any of these other states
as gensake overtly admitted this is just
about spite and it's about ire it's
about nastiness and it's about people
dying and they don't care
this administration is a bleep show it
is a highly political belief show again
jared kushner was raked over the cold
for the suggestion that he was branching
out ventilators which by the way have
turned out to be one of the worst things
for covet but he was ripped up and down
for the suggestion that was never
verified that he was trashing out
ventilators by political preference of
states
that wasn't true he didn't do it didn't
matter he was ripped up and down for it
right he was a bad man the white house
does it openly
openly in front of the press
and everybody's like well you know
that's just the way it goes i mean
rhonda sanchez is a pretty bad guy
meanwhile uh what is all of this really
driven by all of this is driven by a
desire to pin the policy failures of
this administration on the unvaccinated
the idea is we can never go back to
normal until we force everybody to do
what we want and here's the thing we can
you know how i know that i live in a
state that did
many states have done this many states
have this is particularly true for the
vaccinated if you are vaccinated this is
driving me up a damned wall if you're
vaccinated you're safe stop it
stop it everybody is yelling at the
unvaccinated and i understand if you're
unvaccinated and you have any sort of
pre-existing condition and if you don't
have a pre-existing condition your
chances of a side effect from the
vaccine if you are above the age of 18
are significantly lower than your
chances of a side effect from the actual
covet itself the natural immunity you
get from covet is gonna be more durable
than vaccine but
the chances of you getting super sick
from a vaccine are a lot lower than the
chances of you getting super sick from
covet
and that's the stat
now
i understand a lot of people being
peeved at the at the unvaccinated
particularly the unvaccinated who've not
already had covet if you're if you've if
you've already had covet and people are
mad at you i i don't know what to say
those people are idiots if you've
already had covet and the notion is you
must get vaccinated regardless of
whether you have antibodies or t-cell
memory those people are not following
the science but
there's a joe biden is trying to drive
up ire at the unvaccinated let me just
say this to the vaccinated you're
vaccinated you're protected stop this
bull
seriously i know people who are like
double triple vacs have had the boosters
and they're still like i can't go
anywhere near anybody i can't i can't go
anywhere near anyone i can't you know
you have to test before we meet
stop it you're being paranoid at a
certain point somebody's gonna have to
dose you on the reality and the reality
is this disease does not kill a huge
number of people per thousand
not compared to smallpox
and which is a serious disease that
killed one-third of the population
it is more serious than the flu
once you have the vaccine it is
significantly less serious than the flu
this vaccine is a
why am i the only person who is telling
the vaccinated to stop whining you are
now protected i'm vaccinated my parents
are vaccinated i am not afraid for them
i'm not
and honest to god you know who else i am
not afraid for i'm not afraid for my
kids and the reason i'm not afraid for
my kids is because i'm looking at the
statistics
the media don't want you to look at the
stats they want to focus in on anecdotal
evidence every day in the media there's
an article about how
how kids are at significant risk kids
are going to die and then you wait for
them to cite stats and there aren't any
stats there's a piece in the washington
post that says parenting a child under
12 and the age of delta
it's like a fire alarm every day no it's
not i have three children under the age
of 12. you know what would happen if
somebody in their class got delta
nothing i'd send them to school the next
day because i'm not crazy
but you've driven everybody nuts the
media the bite administration they've
driven the vaccinated nuts
i may think it's nutty for a 65 year old
person not to get the vaccine in fact i
do think it's pretty nutty for a 65 year
old person not to get the vaccine if
they've not already had covet i think
that is bad risk assessment i think it
is similarly nutty
maybe even more nutty
to once you have had the vaccine spend
the rest of your life hiding in a bubble
and demanding that the rest of the world
cater to you this is nuts
stop it just stop
kevin i'm going to read you from this
washington post article in a second
because it's just an incredible example
of how the media are garbage at this
they are garbage they've scared people
into unrational unreasoning
tyrant following position that's all
this is at this point cause you can get
back people keep saying when do we get
to go back to normal are you vaccinated
the answer is now
and by the way if you're unvaccinated
you go back to normal too you're just
gonna have to bear the consequences of
that because that's called freedom
it's more of this in a second first the
walk down to the last year and a half
they've created pent-up demand for
places like gyms nail salons hotels all
of them are on an epic hiring spree to
accommodate the surge of business so
where do these businesses turn to fill
these roles fast they turn to zip
recruiter right now you can try it for
free at ziprecruiter.com dailywire when
you post a job on zip recruiter they
send your job to over 100 top job sites
giving you access to their network of
millions of job seekers zip recruiters
matching technology scans resumes to
find qualified candidates for your open
roles and then proactively presents them
to you you can easily review recommended
candidates invite your top choices to
apply for your job that encourages them
to apply faster according to zip
recruiter internal data jobs where
employers invite candidates to apply get
two and a half times more candidates zip
recruiters technology is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the very first day right now you
can try ziprecruiter it's magic try it
for free at this exclusive web address
zip recruiters.com dailywire that is
ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e just go to zip
recruiter.com dailywire zip recruiter is
indeed the smartest way to hire zip
recruiter.com dailywire for your free
trial okay so when i talk about the
media trying to scare the hell out of
you this washington post piece parenting
a child under 12 in the age of delta
it's like a fire alarm every day
routine outings become tricky decisions
for the youngest americans who are still
ineligible for coronavirus vaccines no
no actually no
actually no
again i care about my kids a lot more
than washington post does
i don't want my five-year-old and
seven-year-old who have to mask for the
rest of their lives for a disease that
by infection fatality rate is less
deadly than the flu
my answer to this is no
and if you're living like this i don't
know what to tell you you're crazy
you're being crazy you're being paranoid
and crazy
how do i know because the washington
post can't cite a single damned
statistic in the entire piece quote greg
otto conducts risk assessment
for a living but the cyber security
consultant from springfield never
imagined he'd have to do one every time
his daughter six and son four stepped
outside the boundaries of their home
playing with next-door neighbors
outdoors acceptable school necessary
eating out no way
dan's classes were everyone's mass and
that were pre-paid in june when the
outlook for coronavirus infection seemed
more optimistic on the fence this is
insanity said otto 37 no you are being
insane otto
he says parenting a child under 12 can
be maddening and scary during normal
times but the delta variant has taken
things to a new level
with a vaccine for children aged 5 to 11
unlikely to be approved for at least a
few more months parents of young
children are weighing a dizzying array
of variables every day as they try to
navigate the risks of covet against the
mental health and physical consequences
of social isolation and their own
livelihood briana contreras 33 an
intellectual property attorney whose
children are 6 3 and 20 months said she
and her husband an engineer at los
alamos national lab made the difficult
decision to put all three of their kids
in school or daycare because of their
demanding jobs but she second second
guesses the choice every day
i feel like we're constantly reacting
said contreras there's not enough time
to be proactive it's like a fire alarm
every day in crofton maryland lisa dykes
a graphic designer and mother of two
aged 7 and 11 has been thinking a lot
about a cartoon she recently saw that
featured a parent staring at a vast
ocean she recalled that it said
something like only one percent of the
children are going to get eaten by the
shark it's fine
but it's not one percent of the children
that's incorrect
okay if one percent of kids were dying
from covid after having gotten covered
then we'd be then we would be still
socially isolating that's not the
statistic out of 73 million amer 73
million americans in the united states
under the age of 18. according to the
cdc last i checked which was three days
ago
deaths
412.
that is not 1 in 100 that's 73 million
divided by 412
which is one in every 177
184 people under the age of 18.
what in the hell are you talking about
dykes 48 said the continued reassurances
by health officials and experts that
children are at low risk are difficult
to relate to when you are faced with
your own children
no it just means you're bad at risk
assessment
because literally that that risk
assessment exists every day you know
it's more dangerous than delta to your
kids putting your kids in the car and
taking them to school
the car ride is probably more dangerous
to your kids
than actually sending them to school
with other kids
even school which seemed like a hopeful
and sensibly calculated risk in may she
said now feels like an incredibly
dangerous roll of the dice to whom
to whom
so finally they get to the stats
okay they say there have been just the
the american academy of pediatrics
reported over 250 000 new coronavirus
infections in children just last week
nearly 30 000 adolescents and children
are hospitalized with coveted august
many are unvaccinated teens and tweens
or newborns to 11 year olds who are not
eligible yet for shots
460 have died representing 0.01
of all child cases let me translate that
0.01 percent
one percent is
point one percent is one in a thousand
point zero one percent is one in ten
thousand
one in ten thousand
of the people who have actually been
identified as infected which is way low
because you know how many asymptomatic
kids are walking around infected a hell
of a lot so it isn't actually one in ten
thousand
it is one in probably fifty or sixty
thousand because for every one
identified case there are probably five
that are unidentified
and then the washington post just
decides to scare you with vagueness
right the risks have long covered in
children which could include respiratory
or cardiac problems fatigue brain fog
and other symptoms that can last for
months or potentially years remain a big
unknown
an israeli study one of the first on the
topic of 13 864 children published this
week found 11 of those infected had
signs of long covet however the israeli
health ministry emphasized that some of
the children's symptoms may be due to
prolonged lockdowns school closures and
global conflict including being locked
in your basement while hamas rockets
fight rain down upon your family
yes it turns out that it's quite
stressful for children not to be allowed
to live a regular life that puts them in
a brain fog
also why don't we get any
comparable statistics
now
right before you know i had on scott
gottlieb former fda commissioner i asked
him about this i asked him about masking
children and he said well you know we've
heard studies that suggest that there
are some neurological effects to a small
percentage of children like two percent
of kids might have some long-lasting
symptoms according to british studies
and that may include some neurological
effects okay how about some comps from
flu for example
because it turns out that pretty much
every virus has a small percentage of
people who have long lasting effects
there's no evidence that this is
wildly out of proportion with regard to
delta
so again this is all an attempt to scare
the living hell out of you based on like
they say follow the science and then
they don't follow the science and they
run articles every day not following the
science by the way new study today
okay this is a study from the lancet
that suggests that kids are not
transmitting at the same rate as adults
even in delta world few close contacts
in school are testing positive
so
you know i don't know what to tell you
like this is all directed at either at
your fellow human beings are you at the
people who live with you
and all you can do to drive the tyranny
is bad medical misinformation
and it's it's
at this point
man our society is sick if it accepts
this sort of crap seriously
redistributing monoclonal lands bodies
not on the basis of need but on the
basis of politics is disgusting
telling people that they ought to be far
more scared than they are based on the
actual risk numbers is disgusting and
the media are participating it every day
just as it is wrong and was always wrong
to underplay risks of covid it is
seriously wrong to wildly overplay risks
of covid particularly for kids to scare
the living hell out of parents so they
do unreasonable things that damage their
children it's dumb and it's wrong
but that's what the bible administration
wants to do for pure spiteful politics
it's amazing all the things they they
accuse trump of doing they do themselves
it is all projection
in just a second we'll get to the
biden's border activity because let me
just
tell you what they're doing on the
border right now similarly crazy
similarly tyrannical we'll get to that
in one second first the ben shapiro show
is proud to be supported by grand canyon
university it's an affordable christian
university one of the largest fastest
growing universities in the country it's
located in sunny phoenix arizona gcu is
ranked top 20 for best college campuses
in america it offers over 275 engaging
academic programs with over 240 online
gcu integrates the free market system
with a welcoming christian worldview
perspective into its academic programs
so you can put your faith into action
and help transform communities in 2020
gcu students received over 290 million
dollars in scholarships with many
attending gcu for less than the cost of
a state university i've been to gcu it
is a gorgeous campus the kids there are
wonderful they have great classes
terrific population you're gonna love
going there if you're looking at college
you really should be checking out gcu
find your purpose at gcu private
christian affordable visit gcu.edu my
offer to see what scholarships you
qualify for and that's
gcu.edu my offer and see if you qualify
for some of their scholarships again
they give out hundreds of millions of
dollars of scholarships every single
year gcu.edu
my offer to get started already in just
one second we'll get to joe biden and
the border because that's another
disaster on his hands
one thing is obvious biden has made one
thing incredibly clear he's going full
authoritarian the vaccine mandate is
just the beginning last thursday he
announced his plan to mandate vaccines
for all companies with over 100
employees or forced them to test for
cove at least once a week many companies
are actually forcing their employees to
pay for the tests the daily wire has
over 100 employees so we are one of the
companies who have been mandated by this
idiotic federal government we are not
doing this we are going to sue them the
minute they come down with the
regulation we will find ourselves in
court so let me remind you i am
vaccinated i'm vex i love the vaccine i
can't say this enough because joy reid
will just lie about me on msnbc like she
did last night on yom kippur okay i am
vaccinated no one on planet earth is as
pro-vaccine as i am apparently because i
am not only vaccinated i believe they
work and act accordingly but here's the
thing i'm not going to get on board with
a mandate that is authoritarian
especially because the vaccines work so
here at the daily wire we're not doing
this for this we could face up to a 14
000 fine for every violation i can't
think of a better reason to let the
fines pile up and for opposing medical
tyranny and the erasure of freedom so we
are calling on all who are listening to
help us fight this obscene and
tyrannical mandate if you join us as a
daily wire member right now you'll be
giving us the resources we need to stop
this nonsense take it all the way to the
supreme court if necessary go to
dailywire.com subscribe use code do not
comply at checkout for 25 off americans
have been ceding their freedoms to
authoritarian bureaucrats in the name of
public health over and over and over
again so
it's time to stand up stand with us at
daily wire and with your fellow
americans you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
meanwhile on the border we have a
continuing slow rolling crisis that has
been completely ignored by the media
because kamahara solves it right i mean
we sent our wonderful vice president
down to the border to laugh at it and
went away after she laughed apparently
or alternatively we have thousands of
people who are being held under an
overpass
in texas right now according to the
daily wire the buy administration has
now moved to shut down drones flying in
an area along the u.s southern border
where the administration has thousands
upon thousands of migrants being held
under an overpass so it's basically like
los angeles
fox news reported that according to law
enforcement sources the majority of
those being held under the overpass are
haitian the report comes as the biden
administration once again suffered a
catastrophic month at the border for the
month of august according to reports
this week fox news reporter bill malugan
tweeted quote we've learned that the faa
just implemented a two-week temporary
flight restriction over the
international bridge in del rio texas
meaning we can no longer fly our fox
drone over it to show images of the
thousands of migrants
why
faa says special security reason
so they don't want any pictures of the
thousands of migrants who are now being
housed under an overpass because of this
ridiculous derelict administration
mclugan said quote fox news has been
covering the border non-stop for almost
seven months now we use the drone
constantly it's never been an issue the
border patrol requested a temporary
flight restriction due to drones
interfering with law enforcement flights
on the border as with any temporary
flight restriction media is able to call
the faa to make requests to operate in
the area
earlier in the day he had tweeted our
drone is back over the international
bridge in del rio per source the number
of migrants waiting to be processed has
now swelled to 8 200. it was 4 000
yesterday doubled in one day border
patrol is overwhelmed i'm told the
situation is out of control
according to malugan law enforcement
source on the ground at the bridge this
morning just sent me a video showing the
situation there i'm told a large
majority of the migrants are haitians
more are crossing into the us and
arriving at the bridge by the minute
border patrol is limited in its manpower
so there are currently 8 000 migrants
waiting to be processed fox news reports
there were more than 20 there were more
than 200 000 migrant encounters at the
southern border in august that's
according to a dh source told fox news
on wednesday the second month in a row
where the number has been over the 200
000 mark as migrants continue to attempt
to enter the united states additionally
the 209 000 number for august represents
a 317 percent increase over last august
2020 which saw 50 000 encounters
so that is a rather large increase
chad wolf the former dhs secretary
slammed the administration saying
biden's failed border patrol policies
are simply unsustainable which of course
is true
they basically opened the door and said
come right in and then occasionally said
well you might want to slow that down uh
and it's not working
so joe biden has a solution for all this
and that is just continue spending the
money
so we've had some pretty significant
inflation i've been less worried about
the inflation all along and i've said
this on the show many times and i have
about the stagnation that is likely to
follow the inflation
what happens when the federal government
is trying to shovel money out the door
not only via direct stimulus but via
zero interest rates or negative interest
rates and nobody's taking the loans what
happens then what happens if the demand
is not pressed forward because there is
no new product being developed because
of all the regulations and restrictions
being put on businesses and the taxes
being put on businesses what happens
then
that's the real question joe biden
however has an idiotic idea and that is
if he tosses more money into the economy
somehow this will stop inflation which
must make sense in his adult brain
my republican friends talk a lot about
inflation
but if you want to talk about actually
lowering the cost of living for people
in this country
my plan does just that
by strengthening
the capacity of our economy we'll also
reduce inflationary pressures over the
long run
oh it's going to reduce inflation
amazing well throwing money at things
reduces inflation who who knew this is a
new idea of how inflation gets reduced
when literally the definition of
inflation is too many dollars following
too little product
and then joe biden says you know what
this is fiscally responsible yes nothing
says fiscal responsibility quite like
blowing out the spending in the middle
of an inflationary cycle in the middle
of a natural economic recovery because
of the greatest artificial shock to an
economy in the history of the world
here's joe biden fiscal response like
everything he says just think the
opposite and you're pretty much on
target
my plan is paid for
it's fiscally responsible
because our investments are paid for by
making sure that corporations wealthy
americans pay their fair share
second
we're not going to raise taxes on anyone
making under four hundred thousand
dollars that's a lot of money
some of my liberal friends are saying it
should be lower than that
but only corporations and people making
over four hundred thousand dollars a
year you're going to pay any additional
tax
okay that's a lie he's not telling you
the truth he has a bunch of tobacco
taxes in there also when you tax
corporations what do they do they lower
salary to compensate they raise prices
to compensate
direct taxation is not the only way to
raise taxes on people and force them to
pay more money
his approval rating not coincidentally
is now at the lowest point of his
presidency that of course is not a great
shock 50 percent is approving 44 is
proving
okay so let's talk about that why is joe
biden's approval rating in the toilet
well it's in the toilet because again we
were promised two things a dead
president and a president who is not
going to do a lot of things we thought
those were the same thing wrong it turns
out that the president being not alive
and the president doing things are
actually not mutually exclusive you have
a dead president who does a lot of stuff
as it turns out he is pushing an
unsustainable policy that is rooted
again in radical leftist groupthink
the key is he's not talking about
economic growth right he doesn't care
about economic growth he's talking
openly about quote-unquote fairness
whenever the left says fairness
understand that their fairness comes at
real cost to somebody if they're talking
about vaccine equity they're talking
about somebody dying who shouldn't have
to die because their notions of fairness
ought to trump that person's life when
they talk about tax equity they don't
mean that you should pay a percentage of
your income
equivalent to your percentage of of
the income that you make on a global
basis they don't mean that they don't
mean that you should pay a flat rate
across because that's what percentages
are they are flat rates yeah they don't
mean that when they say fairness what
they actually mean is they don't care if
they kill the economy so long as they
get to go after people they don't like
they get to go after the rich and eat
the rich that's all they care about as
someone aptly pointed out after the
irrepressible incredible incomparable so
fresh so face aoc or a dress reading tax
the rich to the met gala you'll notice
that her dress didn't read help the poor
correct it is all about spite for the
wretch it's all about if you earn a lot
of money in this country there's a group
of people who hate your guts unless
you're a big celebrity who pats them on
the head and tells them what a wonderful
person they are and that way you can
earn your way out of the ire of people
like aoc and you can hobnob with her and
take some pictures it's pretty great
but it really is about spite fairness
for the left means spite for the radical
left this does not mean economic growth
it does not mean any articulable
principle
of of actual
equality it just means spite so here's
joe biden being spiteful he says i need
to raise taxes on billionaires because
billionaires are making too much money
and in the process you'll see he
conflates two forms of money making
income and wealth these are not the same
thing here he is conflating them
ceos used to make about 20 times the
average worker in the company that they
ran
today they make more than
350 times
what the average worker in the
corporation makes
since the pandemic began
billionaires have seen their wealth go
up by
1.8 trillion dollars that is everyone
was a billionaire before the pandemic
began
the total accumulated wealth beyond the
billions they already had
has gone up by
1.8 trillion dollars
simply not fair
okay well um actually when he says
simply not fair i don't know what his
alternative is so if you want to say
simply not fair for for big companies to
be worth more money then maybe you
shouldn't have shut down the entire
damned economy on behalf of the wealthy
maybe you shouldn't have done that
see i can tell you what's particularly
inequitable about what joe biden has
done policy-wise and that is he is
currently putting mandates on all
businesses above 100 employees which is
a lot of mid-sized and fairly small
businesses
for the benefit of giant businesses who
are all perfectly happy with joe biden
they're all perfectly overjoyed with joe
biden for doing this
and joe biden is happy with regulatory
capture on behalf of giant corporations
then donate money to him
he's taken half of the small businesses
in the country off the table
blue state governors continue to do so
on behalf of giant companies that can
absorb some cost in order to knock their
competitors out of business so if you
want to talk about inequitable
distribution you might want to talk
about regulation that is specifically
designed to help the biggest players
while killing the people in the middle
but that's not what he's talking about
he's saying that whatever company exists
at the top whether it is justified or
not that company being wealthier needs
to pay more taxes okay wealth is not
income
if you own a house in the united states
today you are wealthier than you were
two years ago
now you might be unemployed now and you
weren't unemployed two years ago so long
as you've been paying that mortgage and
you're still on your house
you're wealthier because the real estate
prices went up should you pay taxes on
that
nope
you should not because you did not
realize the gain the difference between
wealth and income
is constantly being elided by democrats
they'll say things like well you know
that person has a lot of wealth is what
elizabeth warren does she has a this
person has a lot of wealth it's a lot of
like mark zuckerberg that dude is worth
a hundred billion dollars
okay when you say worth a hundred
billion dollars you mean he owns at the
currently valued stock price a hundred
billion dollars of facebook stock
now is he liquid
has he realized the purchase price of
that stock the answer is no because the
minute let's say the mark zuckerberg
decided i'm selling all my stock in
facebook that stock would not be worth
100 billion dollars because his mere
selling of his stock would tank the
stock
and pretending that wealth and income
are the same thing is idiotic as i
mentioned
you might be very wealthy by elizabeth
warren standards because you're worth
hundreds of thousands of dollars because
you own a house
have you sold the house have you taken
out money against the house if not
you're not realizing the value of the
house are you
the same thing is true in the stock
market if you haven't sold your stock
you've not realized the gain or loss
yet this is the game that joe biden
wants to play for fairness purposes and
when he says that ceos are now earning
so much more than employees
yes because they run much larger
companies than they did 20 30 years ago
it turns out that the people who are
making policy for thousands of employees
tend to earn proportionally a lot more
than people who are making policy for
four employees that is not a shock
that is because they are charged with
making sure that all of those people get
paid it's a much larger job requiring
much larger decisions that impact many
many more people
but again none of this matters the world
of economic reality
makes no difference to to joe biden it
is completely by the way when he talks
about ceo pay very often he's not
talking about yearly salary many of the
ceos take one dollar salaries he's
talking about things like stock options
he's talking about things like parachute
plans and these are all ways that you
woo ceos
none of this is fiscally responsible all
of it is simple pandering
so it is no shock that you are seeing
quote unquote moderate senators like joe
manchin and kristin cinema basically
being like nope we're not doing any of
this crap
according to the washington post senate
democrats were riding high on the
afternoon of july 28th a long delayed
bipartisan infrastructure package had
finally come together many senators
eager to finish that bill and move
forward with a multi-trillion dollar
piece of economic climate and social
legislation president biden's signature
build back better plan but one senator
senator kirsten cinema punctured the
gleeful atmosphere with a warning shot
while democratic members of the senate
budget committee may have agreed on the
size of the second bill she had not she
said i don't support a bill that costs
3.5 trillion dollars
cinema said in a statement that struck
some of her fellow democrats as poorly
timed oh no it's well timed she was
saying the only way we're getting the
infrastructure package is if you shrink
this other package over here and
meanwhile the progressives are like we
don't like that so we're not going to do
it
cinema has stayed silent on all of this
manchin has been out front taking the
bullet mansion's been saying no i'm not
going along with this 3.5 trillion
dollar plan and this is all getting
wrapped up into tax debate as well
because cinema and mansion are not on
board with these massive tax increases
that would make our corporate tax rate
higher than china's
meanwhile the democrats are facing a bit
of a deadline here again you wonder why
joe biden is failing because he's
failing on every front there is not a
front on which joe biden is succeeding
right now not one
it's why he's getting desperate it's why
he's blaming his fellow americans that's
why he's blaming americans left in
afghanistan for being left in
afghanistan that's why he's blaming the
unvaccinated for his own failure to
simply say to people once you're
vaccinated go out and live your life
which is a very easy thing to say
and he's failing when it comes to his
fiscal policy right now democrats have a
world of hurt on their hands because the
debt ceiling debate is about to happen
they have the votes to pass the debt
ceiling but they're not going to and
they're going to try and blame
republicans for it it's not going to
work because they have a majority in the
senate a majority in the house
according to politico democrats are
taking their first concrete steps to
avert a government shutdown in two weeks
even as they struggle to wrangle a
master plan for handling multiple fiscal
cliffs ahead
president joe biden held a joint call
with house speaker nancy pelosi and
senate majority leader chuck schumer on
thursday afternoon while top democrats
mulled their options for handling both
the september 30th funding deadline and
the impending debt cliff the house rules
committee is scheduled to meet tuesday
to tee up the stopgap spending bill for
a floor vote next week text of that
funding measure has not been released
the patch is likely to keep government
agencies open into december setting up
another critical funding deadline ahead
of the holidays top lawmakers are
leaning toward december 10th for the end
date but have also left over left open
december 3rd as a possibility
meanwhile majority party leaders are
deciding whether to pair the must-pass
funding package to avoid a shutdown with
a measure to tackle the approaching debt
cliff
republicans say we're going to reject
this i will allow you to continue paying
the bills for now but we're not going to
raise the debt ceiling for you
a bill that addresses both fiscal
threats would likely pass the house but
the odds are highly questionable in the
senate or all but four gop lawmakers
have promised to vote against raising
the debt limit
the premise that republicans are not
going to vote in any way shape or form
or fashion for a debt limit increase is
the correct premise that's not happening
democrats would be remiss to pass the
funding bill without debt limit action
since the treasury department is
expected to run out of borrowing ability
sometime next month a breaking point
likely to trigger economic turmoil
majority party leaders can maximize
their leverage over republicans by
coupling the issues forcing gop
lawmakers to either fall in line or go
on record against billions of dollars in
disaster aid preventing a government
shutdown and avoiding debt default so
republicans are saying listen we're not
raising the debt limit just so that you
guys can blow out the spending some more
we're not going to do that so democrats
are like okay fine what we'll do is
we'll pass one bill it includes a bunch
of government spending you guys want and
increasing the debt limit and
republicans are like fine do it we'll
just vote against it ben cardin says the
debt limit is something we should do
almost automatically any opportunity we
have to pass it the sooner the better
wherever we can get a bill in i hope we
can get the debt limit seal it the debt
ceiling included in it
earlier this week some senate
republicans indicated a willingness to
support a stopgap bill including
billions of bucks in hurricane and flood
relief requested by biden but any
measure to raise or suspend the debt
limit must be left off said gop
lawmakers
insisting the democrats handle this
issue alone since the majority party is
pursuing multi-trillion dollar spending
plans without republican support so in
other words we're not going to raise the
debt limit just so you guys can ram
through a giant 3.5 trillion dollar
package
senator chuck grassley he said he's not
going to support a continuing resolution
this way he says the debt limit is all
justifying they're robbing the bank to
spend a whole bunch of news to to spend
a whole bunch of new social programs
that are going to feed the fires of
inflation
so democrats are basically left with a
choice do they go for joe biden's 3.5
trillion dollar plan and not get the
debt limit increase because they don't
have the 60 votes necessary to move past
the filibuster
or do they kill joe biden's signature
spending but which by the way doesn't
even have democratic support mansion and
cinema aren't on board
there's it's no re there's a reason why
joe biden's ratings are down you can
sense the media starting get itchy
nbc's kelly o'donnell actually had the
temerity to ask the white house why joe
biden coughs it so much yesterday here
was that
we've seen him on many occasions where
he has a repeated cough
what is the situation with that cough
and is that a concern i don't think it's
an issue of concern i think there are a
range of reasons why we may need to
clear our throat or we may have a little
light cold
and that's certainly something that
presidents elected officials reporters
uh spokespeople uh can confront but it's
not an area where we have a medical
concern
and the fact that people are asking that
is just a cover for the fact that people
on the left in the media they're sensing
this guy is his toast he's got a real
problem on his hands joe biden does not
have a floor he only has a ceiling
obama had a floor and a ceiling trump
had a floor and a ceiling joe biden has
a ceiling in terms of approval rating
but no floor that's a real problem for
them and they know it alrighty we'll be
back here later today with an additional
hour of content first you cannot forget
to end your week by checking out the
andrew clavin show drew's shows every
friday he's got an exciting evening
planned for you head on over to
dailywire.com at 7 pm eastern 6 pm
central tune in i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin